Let's look at modern remote
debugging with Chrome.
I'm going to take
the URL of this demo
and open it up in
Chrome on Android.
And now on the remote debugging
page, we see its GPU layers.
More on that later.
What I really want to show
you is this-- Screencast.
You're looking at the
live view of Chrome
on Android on your machine.
It shows exactly what's
happening on the device
all the time.
But better than that, you can
actually interact with it.
So typing here with
my fingers is slow.
Let's switch the keyboard.
Yeah, so all keystrokes are
sent down to the device.
And clicks and drags are
sent down as touches, too.
You can scroll with
your mouse wheel
or trackpad and see your
device scroll with you.
Probably my favorite is--
yep, inspect element.
It works the way
you'd want it to,
selecting the elements
in the device's browser
and manipulating them directly.
Now back to those GPU layers.
Here's a complex 3D
CSS transform scene.
And DevTools gives us insight
on the live layer tree
composition.
Similarly Screencasted
remote debugging
works great with
the web GL profiler.
Please try all this out today.
For how, just google
for remote debugging.